jetzt reicht's jemand muss wieder für
die deutsche wurst kämpfen für die welt
wurst conchita kommen
[Musik]
da ist wieder mit markus ronge ich habe
mit einem dampfstrahler bin ich eben
noch über den schimmel drüber gegangen
an der außenhaut das ist alles weg das
kann man prima essen konnte mal
versuchen
scheiß auf den schimmel sagte hauptsache
es schmeckt ja genau
hört sich an wie weg das ist
messerscharf beobachtet aber wilke ist
der der in verruf geraten ist und wir
sind wir sind die besseren
wir sind die mitbewerber wir haben die
gleichen methoden aber uns hat man nicht
erwischt es ist auch lehrreichen wird
nach wenigen minuten tot bin
jetzt sind sie aber auch ein bisschen
kleinlich
dann nimmt das kind schon wie gesagt das
gesicht nicht zeigen aber sie sehen das
kind greift schon automatisch nach der
wurst das ist so eine art natur reflex
buch warum nicht meint meiner rede
conchita kommst du mal bitte guck mal da
das ein bisschen schimmel macht mal
wieder weg so sieht sehr schön aus
mehr kein schwein wie kann man essen
weißen so ruhig mal rein
da habe ich eben erst den schimmel
abgekratzt also und schmeckt trotzdem
noch gut bei klausel könnte es
wahrscheinlich anpassen aber das halt so
besser ist es so weil wie gesagt wollen
sie wissen was alles aber billig ist es
die größten denker waren alles veganer
ob dessen bruder ist ob das geox goethe
ist adolf hitler ist nein den wohl noch
nicht dazu rechne aber veganer welche
wurst immer ein genuss deutsche wurst
ist top egal was kommt
das macht uns keiner nach das ist
wirklich nicht das macht uns keiner
[Musik]
hans de schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [ __ ]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen freundin
trennen freund rennkurs mit herz vielen
dank für ihr freundliches feedback für
ein exklusives geigensolo von oliver
welke
abonnieren sie den kanal